Hello world,
it's a Raj and supply chains.
I know it doesn't sound like the
sexiest word ever, but it is a very,
very important industry that AI can
be applied to an improved greatly.
There's a huge potential there.
In this video we're going to improve the
revenue streams for a simulated company
using this logistics wizard that
IBM has provided. What this is,
is it's an example of how AI can be used
to optimize the supply chain for some
distribution company.
So for those of you who don't know,
a supply chain is the process of taking,
of taking an item from raw
materials into a finished product.
And there's a lot of
middlemen along the way.
So anything you order on
Amazon prime for it to go from,
from where it is to you,
all of that is the supply chain.
And there are distributors,
there are, uh, you know, drivers,
all sorts of different middlemen in the
middle and the weather affects the price
of the shipment. There's all of these
variables and this is imperfect,
perfect example of how AI can be used to,
to make a process more efficient.
And so what this is is it's a simulated
demo of a global logistics company.
And what they do is they ship products,
they've got three distribution centers,
five active shipments, one has been
completed, and for retail centers,
this is where the product is
actually sold to consumers.
And what we can do is we can
simulate a storm using this button.
So hits simulate storm.
And what's going to happen is it's going
to simulate a storm. It's a snow storm,
it's a moderately severe snow storm.
And what happened because of the storm,
because of the storm,
we have uh,
had supply shortages in these two cities
from salt lake to Raleigh and from Salt
Lake to Boston. And I can either
approve these Aurukun deny these,
I'll say approved for the first
one and reject the second one.
And what this is going to do to my bottom
line as let's say I'm the CEO of this
company, is it's going to either
increase my revenue or lose it. Okay.
So that's the demo and we're
going to look at that at the end.
I'm also going to explain the like the
technical details of what's happening
behind the hood here, how
it's doing that, but you know,
high level if you just want to try it out
without like having to code or looking
at the technical details,
this IBM demo link in the description
is perfect for you anyway, so,
right,
so like I said,
the supply chain is that network between
a company and its suppliers to produce
and distribute a specific product and
the supply chain represents the steps it
takes to get that product to the consumer.
So we can see this nice little
infographic we have to start,
which is a factory and this person
or robot. Then the forecasts,
ideally using AI right now
it's done mostly using humans.
It forecasts the demand.
How many people are going to want this
product and based on that forecast,
they will create enough product from raw
material to meet that demand and then
they're going to allocate all
of that onto these trucks.
They're going to optimize the routes
without these trucks take to get to the
consumer.
They're going to assort all of those
finished products in those boxes in the
distribution factory and then send them
to the retail center and hopefully,
hopefully more customers buy the
product. There is actually profit, right?
Hopefully there is profit after this
giant process and it's a very long and
complicated process to go
through, right? I mean there's,
there's so many middlemen here,
but the problem is that what if the
consumer doesn't like it? Right?
Ideally you want to cut your losses as a
business and right now there are people,
consulting firms, agencies that companies
hire to do this and they're very,
very expensive.
Companies lose a lot of money due to
the supply chain and if you as a small
startup can save any company,
even 5% on their transportation costs
because you're using AI to optimize the
ideal time that they
should send this shipment.
Factoring in the weather conditions,
factoring in consumer demand,
can factoring in whatever it is, if you
can show to them that you can do that,
not only is that a big deal,
you will get paid so much money.
There is so much money to be made
into supply chain. Okay. I've been,
I've been researching this. There's,
so there's a lot of money. Seriously.
This AI for business series
me basically being like,
how can have you applies to this whole, my
God, this, what am I doing with my life?
I need to know. But anyway, I
want you guys to make money.
You know what I'm saying? Like we're,
we're a crew, we're homies, you know,
you guys make money, I get
happy. That's just how it works.
And I've got my paid course in book
sales and ad revenue and Patriot and,
um, speaking deals and other things that
I do for revenue. So with that, I'm good.
Uh,
someone said in the last video,
like show a little glimpse
of the real survived.
So I'm showing you that also
one more guns to the real Saroj.
I'm in New York right now in
my makeshift studio and uh,
I'm here for this Crypto, a award
thing, which I thought like,
should I even go to that? But, um,
I'm here because like, it's cool.
I went to this cosmos,
a party last night.
Cosmos is a really cool
a blockchain network.
They're one of the few
that I actually like. Um,
they helped me make Suraj coined back
in a few days ago, which not a few days,
a few weeks ago,
months even,
which I don't think it worked out
because people took it the wrong way.
But the point is that they're, they're
pretty cool and um, anyway, so yeah,
it's good to be in New York anyway.
So the supply chain,
there's a lot of components there, right?
There's requirements, planning, sourcing,
manufacturing, all of these requirements.
And right now this, in this,
in this infographic here,
you're seeing artificial intelligence,
all of that is done by
humans. I mean, seriously,
this is a very old industry,
right?
This is like as old as products themselves
have been and no one has even thought
about applying AI to it until the
past five or six years ago. Right?
Because that's when deep learning
really started like two to come into the
mainstream. The other reason
is because there's so much
data, right? The suppliers,
manufacturers, distributors,
they have so much data.
I have a sample data set for you
right here to take a look at. Okay.
This is just a very small example that
I found from what was a key data.com and
its supply chain shipping pricing data.
Okay.
So they have some project code and this
is like real world data. Like it's,
it's not pretty, it looks ugly. You're
like what is this? What am I looking at?
What am I even trying to do here?
If you're,
if that's the case then you're looking
at some really real, real world data.
Cause that's how it looks.
It's our job as data scientists to find
the needle in the haystack to find the,
the three keys in the,
the simulation as a ready player.
One was in that movie. That's
how it was. So, um, anyway,
so we've got country, these are
all features and w okay, so let's,
let's think through this for a second.
Let's say this is our data set, right?
Like scheduled delivery date
clients. Okay. Wow. Okay.
Sub Classification. Okay.
There's a, there's a label
that we could potentially use,
you know, all of these
different things. Okay?
So there's,
there's quite a lot of features here.
But remember if this can
easily be a supervised learning
problem where we have a
label and then we had the input data,
right?
So all we have to do is we have to decide
what that label is going to be, right?
It could be, you know, what is the,
we want to predict what
the weight is going to be.
We want to predict what the fright cost
is going to be given all of these other
conditions.
Let's say it's that we want to predict
what the cost is going to be given all of
these other features, okay?
So we can easily do that
with psych. It learn, right?
We split the training data and two,
this is the x and here's the why.
The why is the cost.
The X is everything else.
And what this is going to amount to is a
giant matrix, right? We're all of these
values right here are going to
constitute a single data point,
which is a single matrix,
right?
Value one comma value to comma
bio about you three comma.
But notice how some of these are dates.
Some of these are strings,
some of these are numbers.
What we want to do first is to
regularize all of this data.
So it's all numerical, right? And we'll
just, once it's all numbers, right,
then we can feed it to the
neural network or whatever,
whatever we're going to use probably a
neural network because that's the best
for sure. So once we do that and
we, so we have the input data,
we have the labels and we're
predicting the mapping.
Remember it's all about
predicting that mapping.
And once we predicted that mapping after
a sufficient number of data points,
then we'll say,
you know what?
Let's say I'm going to deliver it on.
And you say some date in the future,
you say, okay, on this day and
with this kind of client with this,
what's the price going to be?
And it's going to tell you
based on everything else,
here's the likely costs and
it's going to cost you. Okay,
so but I think a good way to do this,
that's one way.
I mean notice there's so many
things we could predict, right?
We could predict the the, the, the
class label that is going to be,
it's going to be an HIV test
is going to be pediatric.
That won't necessarily be good for us,
but we could do that.
But what I think would be
the most efficient would
be time series forecasting,
right?
On what date should I send
out this shipment such that
the price is going to be
the lowest.
So that is considered time series
forecasting and notice how,
how many features there are.
We could not draft this alone,
this data set just like this.
We would have to reduce the
dimensionality of this Dataset, right?
Using a technique like Tsne or PCA,
right?
Which is principle component analysis.
Both of those, those techniques.
I have videos on search to Raj,
PCA, Saroj, t dash, s, n, e.
And then once we do that,
then it's going to be a two dimensional
graph where it's going to be one
dimension is going to be everything,
all the features.
And the other dimension is
going to be the time, right?
Every single day of
the month and the year.
And it's going to plot out
what that looks like. Okay.
And so what we wanna do is we
want to find that lowest point.
And what we can do is
once we grab that out,
we could see what that lowest
point is and then we can say, well,
this is the optimal point right here.
So that's another way we can do this.
But if we're trying to figure out the
best date to ship something based on the
weather pattern, that's easily a
time series forecasting problem,
which we can do with chaos, which I'll
show you at the end of this video. Um,
but anyway, so that's, that's
a, that's a little bit of a,
a Dataset Speil for you anyway.
But the problem with supply chains,
and there is a big problem, is that
there are, there are these silos, right?
There are silos. It's,
it's not easy to just say,
I'm going to make an AI startup
gimme your supply chain.
Like it's like one big Dataset.
It's not always, you know, they're,
they're different companies that deal
with all of these things that require
armies of expensive planners and they
usually run complex engines at each step
of the process and at each
node in the supply network.
So they are missing out on these huge
opportunities because there locally
optimized for their own, you
know, their own little silo.
But if someone could get an
overhead view of all of the data,
you could optimize the f out of
everything, which is awesome, right?
So that's what we want to do.
We want to get that huge end to end
data set of the entire supply chain.
And so if we look at, you know, people
were surveyed, companies were surveyed,
what the most costly outcomes were
for, uh, for their supply chains.
And most people said margin erosion. And
the second one was sudden demand change,
which is also a big one,
right?
So suddenly people don't want the product
or suddenly you know the margin is the
margin has eroded or whatever it is,
which I assume is like the product margin.
Like let's say the cost of the raw
materials went up for some reason like oil
for example, because of political
reasons or whatever, what have you.
But that that's a huge deal as well.
And you can predict all of these things.
You can predict that a
product is going to fail.
You can predict that there's going to be
a disruption in the product, full flow,
all of this, if you pass efficient
data, you can predict these sticks.
This is a super power and think about it.
Most of these companies,
they don't know. They don't know
that anything about this, you know,
you are literally watching a video
on supply chain applied to AI.
So there's a lot of
opportunity in this space.
So supply chains have a lot of
data and it's all sorts of data.
It's transactional data, it's time
based data, it's gps, mapping numbers,
strings, texts, dates. There's a lot,
and we have to regularize all this data
so it's in the same numerical format and
then we can feed it to a
machine learning model,
but they've got so much data and the
AI should not be a black box, right?
Whenever you have a client
accompany a distributor distributor,
you've got to be able to explain to
them why you made a certain decision.
And the best way to do that is to
visualize that data, right? To show them,
here is why. Here are, here's
the point, here's the, you know,
here's the the minimum minimum that
I found. Here's a gradient. You know,
things like that.
You don't have to say the word gradient,
but you have to show them visually
how you came to your conclusion.
That's one way. Another way is, I mean,
depending on the type of
neural network you have,
if it's a convolutional network,
you can show them the features inside.
You could say like, well, here's
the abstractions that it's built.
There's a lot of different ways,
but the point is that you should
be able to explain your findings.
So, uh, what are the different ways
that AI can solve this problem? Right?
So I mean there's so many different ways
that AI could potentially solve this
problem. And if you think about it, what's
really exciting is 13% of companies,
only 13% that were served,
that were surveyed by forester said that
the supply chain was where the focus of
AI was in internally, which is huge,
right? And it's going everywhere else,
marketing, sales, other
areas. But it's such a, it's,
there's so much data there in that
field and there's so much potential for
increasing revenue, right? By
streamlining and optimizing the whole,
the whole process.
So it's a huge opportunity for startups.
And so if you think about it,
the supply chain,
all the people who are planning it,
the drivers for the cars,
the people who are unpacking boxes,
who are checking for quality,
all these things, every single part of
that can be optimized, can be automated.
And if you think about the Internet
of things and Mike Drop blockchain,
we can create a fully, fully,
fully autonomous system
here and to end autonomous,
no humans needed, um, that
can be self aware, self
governing and self determining.
And I'll add to that self optimizing,
right?
It just gets better and better over time.
So,
and the reason I say blockchain is
because right now we trust middlemen with
saying that a package was sent from point
a to point B and we have to pay those
middlemen.
But ideally we could use some kind of
immutable ledger blockchain that nobody
controls and say.
And every time a shipment is sent it's
timestamped on to that blockchain.
And then we can say, hey, oh it was
there. Right? This is when it happened.
It's on this blockchain, its
immutable, nobody modified it.
I don't have to trust anybody. So that's
how blockchain can be used here as well.
Timestamping shipments and when they
happen and when different actions occur,
it's a publicly verifiable way.
So what are,
what are startups that have
actually done this? So one idea.
So what are ways that AI can be
applied to this industry? Right?
And I'll talk about startups inside of
this. So one is chatbots for procurement,
right? So whenever you have someone
who is running some kind of company,
they can say, hey, I want to be
able to access, you know, this,
this could be like some data that they
need for the supply chain or whatever.
And the,
the Chat Bot can give them that data.
It can pull it from the Dataset and
say, here it is. They can also say,
you can also ask it like if I were to do
this, what would be the likely outcome?
It can make predictions using a
pretrained model in the background.
So one company that is
doing this is chime box.
So with Chime Bot is doing is they are
acting as a chat bot interface for these
suppliers, right? So, um,
basically, you know, they're,
they're making the chatbot
for different industries,
but procurement is one of them.
And they can ask these questions,
which is super useful because a chat
Bot is 24, seven, it doesn't need sleep.
You don't need to pay it, you know a
lot like it as much as a human and it's,
it's, it's a very optimized um, idea.
So another one is supply chain planning,
which is what we're going to do, right?
So how could an AI be used to
help forecast the inventory?
How much you need planning a
demand supply, these things,
these kinds of things.
Ai is perfectly suited for that.
Clear metal is one startup that
is doing that right now, right?
Supply chain visibility, making predictive
alerting and collaboration possible.
Check them out.
And by the way,
I want to say that none of these
startups should dissuade you from doing
something in this field. There's a
huge opportunity. There's a huge space,
there's a lot to share.
And these are just,
this is just an example for
you to look at it and say,
this is possible machine learning
for warehouse management, right?
If we think about who is in
control of the warehouse,
it's a human need to make sure that the
robots are in order, that the, you know,
this person is getting paid,
et cetera.
And there's a lots for a human
to keep in mind. This is a,
this is a huge job and AI can definitely
help that human or even replace that
human in that job. Rubik cloud is a
good example of intelligent decision.
Autumn is automation. Definitely check
that one out. Autonomous Vehicles,
that one sounds like an obvious one, but
Google Waymo, Uber drive dot. Ai Comma.
Dot. Ai. There's a bunch of, uh,
potential in this space to
create self-driving transports
that can automate the,
the driving process portion
of the supply chain.
And also you don't have to make a
capital intensive car or truck to, to,
to make a self driving, um,
startup. You can make software
for them. You can make a,
you can, you can collect
data, aggregate data,
you can create better mapping software,
et cetera.
There's a lot of potential there as well.
Natural language processing
is another one, right?
So the data that we're looking at is very,
uh, you know, it's hard to read, right?
There's so many different features,
item description delivered to client date,
et cetera.
Ideally we could use natural language
processing to interpret all of this data
and then create a simple Q and a
system where we could just ask this,
ask our Dataset,
what is this?
And it would just find it exactly what
we need and just tell us that exact day.
Like what was the vendor I IMCO
term on the 5th of November, right?
Something like that.
Like an NLP natural language interface
where we can use plain English to ask it
questions and things like that.
Data log. Dot. Io is doing that. Um,
death taxes and data preparation.
You're on your own for death and taxes.
But we've got you covered for data
preparation. I love that. Great.
A great little slogan. So, uh,
last one is a predictive analytics for
supplier selection, right? As you can see,
it's very complicated.
There's a lot of potential decisions
that a human has to make. Your,
anytime you can offload a very hard
decision to a machine, you are, you've,
you've done something very
good for society, right?
So, uh, supplier selection,
who's the best supplier? Who's
going to be the, you know, um,
optimal choice for different actions that
you would perform in the supply chain.
Great example of Ai.
So to get to this logistics wizard
that I was talking about earlier,
so IBM has this service called bloomix.
Bloomix is using their Ai Watson
to do a bunch of different tasks.
So in this case, a task we're looking
at is called the logistics wizard.
And what that does is it's using an AI
to create the simulated environments for
this global retail distribution
company and simulate bad weather.
And so what we can do is we can track
that bad weather, we can trap cars,
our shipments, we could see what's
going wrong, what's going right,
and it will tell us those things.
And it's using an AI to make predictions.
So what we can get into the details of,
you know,
all the different things this can do,
but this is like, uh, you know, ready,
ready to go solution.
And what you can do is you can actually
use this and your tool set for another
company, right? Because there is an
overhead to even having to look at this.
Well you can say,
is it like a plain English direction?
Like here's the best thing to do
based on my data, my analytics.
So you can actually use
this for our company.
You can use this in unison with other
models, care os, tensorflow, Pi Torch,
build your own models,
try out different models for different
use cases and just have all of those in
your tool set, um, to, to, to use
as predicted power for your client.
Now there are different ways to build
a model. Um, if we look at this,
right? It depends on what
we're trying to predict, right?
If we're trying to predict the
label or if the shipment mode,
the fulfillment dates, the
scheduled date, the price,
what are we trying to predict here?
Right?
And that column is going to be our label.
Everything else is going to
be our input data, right?
Which usually in my videos
is just one single column,
but sometimes it can be multiple columns,
right? And that's a little harder, uh, to,
to think about.
But really it's just one giant matrix.
We don't actually have to think about
like how the mapping is working.
We just know that it's going to learn
that mapping. That's really the key.
It's went to learn the mapping between
one or more columns x, you know,
x values and the label, which is whatever
we're trying to predict, the price,
the time,
et cetera.
And so what I want to do right now is I
want to do a little bit of pseudo code
just so you could get an idea of what
I'm talking about here. So let's, let's,
let's see. What we want to do
is we want to predict the, um,
let's say the price.
We want to predict the price of a
shipment given all the other variables.
And what we've done is we have our data
set here, we have our price as well. See,
here's the freight costs and USD
and let's assume where we're,
we've gathered whether data
we've gathered, even stock data,
whatever kind of data.
And we put them all into columns in our
giant Dataset and we want to predict the
price. And so, because time is involved
here, there are dates involved.
What we could consider this as
is a time series problem, right?
We're trying to forecast in a time series
problem. So what I can do is I can say,
okay, this is going to
be my supply chain. Uh,
and I'm going to import the libraries
that I need. That's going to be care os,
that's going to be pan does
for data preprocessing,
that's going to be psychic,
learn for data regularization and um,
it's a pseudo code by the way.
And we'll get to the real code.
I just want to show you how I think and
you know, just think through it with you.
So what are we going to do?
Well,
we're going to create a
function called prediction.
And inside of the prediction function,
we're going to say we've
got our input data.
So is there input data is going to
be a part of a pandas data frame.
Okay.
So this is,
we're pulling this into memory and this
is going to be a input dot CSV file that
we saw and we're going to split
it on let's say the 19th column.
So everything before the 19 column, all
those data points are going to be the x,
right?
The input data.
And the last one is going to be the price
and that's going to be the the label.
And that's all we did. We split the
data into training and testing data. Uh,
well we, we can actually do that
with at Lawrence we can say x, Y,
x test,
why test?
Now we can take that input data,
which is just split and we could say,
we could say sy Kit,
learn dot split,
let,
let's just say it's already split,
but this just kind of format to
into four different variables. Okay.
And so they're, um, important data.
That was our first step.
Then we split data into
training and testing data.
Now we'll build a model build model
using Cara Ross of course,
off subsequential and now we're
going to build our network. Okay.
So we're trying to predict
what that price is going to be.
So what we can do is we could look at
Ken Ross and we could take some of those
snippets here. Let's just say it's
going to be a two layer model.
Everything is fully connected. Uh,
ideally we would want an LSTM network,
which I'm about to show you.
But for the sake of this pseudo code demo,
I'm just trying to show you
like how this goes. Um, lastly,
we're going to fit the model on the
data. We built it, we've compiled it,
we defined it's lost function,
and then at the very end,
we can make our prediction just like that.
And this is going to be x,
and this is gonna be y. And now once
we're done, we'll predict our classes.
And what it's going to do is going to
print out a giant matrix of all of those
features and all the values
given this price, right?
So we're going to make a prediction
about what the features would be given a
price, and then we could give it
some price that we want ideally.
And then we'll say, well,
here's what you should have.
Here are the optimal levels
for all of those features.
And we could just kind of tune it there,
give it more data,
get more accurate results,
et cetera. So, uh,
but what we would want in this case
if we have a lot of data, is an Lstm,
a neural network,
a long short term memory network as a
type of recurrent network. And everyone,
whenever we're dealing
with sequences of data,
we want to use a recurrent network
because the past matters, right?
It's not just learning the mapping the
past matters as well because you can't
just say,
you know,
predict the next word in a sentence
without knowing the words that came before
it because the past matters.
So LSTM networks are a type of recurrent
network that could predict longterm
sequences, which is what we
likely have. And we can, you know,
have some data preprocessing up here to
make sure it's all in the same format.
And then we could just run our
training loop on DLC. I'm network,
very simple stuff. Uh, but yeah, I just
wanted to show you that you can use this,
you can use carrots to build it on
your own. You can find the data set.
I have a link to that in the description.
You can use IBM's blue mix if
you don't want to have to code,
and one a very easy to use solution,
but there's a lot of potential in this
space and I hope you found this video
useful. Also, if you have any
comments, any feedback suggestions,
definitely post them in the comment
section. I always read my comments.
I might not reply to all of them, but I
read all of them. So thanks for watching.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I've got to attend a
crypto award,
so thanks for watching.